HARDEN SEES A SEEM AND JACKS IT
DOWN, A HARRELL.
THREE-TENTHS OF A HARDEN.
AND A STRONG FINISH SHARPE.
HIGR
AFTER BANGER,G IT
DOWN OFF THE NO-LOOK DIME FROT
SPECTACULAR IN HIS AT THAT.
HARDEN, POWERS AHEAD.
DAZZLE FROMM, TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS PLAY.
WHAT A A FINISH.
AND A CHANCE FOR A THREE-POINT
PLAY.COMBINE.
AND A SWITCH, AND HARDEN, AND
DOESN'T HAVE TO GO FOR THE
HOME RUN
THE PICK.
>> Sarah: THE VISION,
UP AHEAD, MILLS HAS THE ANGLE
FOR THE
HARDEN.
>> Mark: HOW ABOUT YOU DO
HAVE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN TOUCH FOR BRO.
THE FOUL.
IS WORRY ABOUT HEH
HARDEN, THAT LEAVES BRUCE
GOES RIGHT AT HARDEN. HARDEN, O,
HE'S FEELING IT NOW.
A SHOT.
>> Ian: NUMBER TWO ON'S SOLO .
STEADY
PRESENCE OF HOW HE'S FOUND HIS
>> Michael: ANOTHER BIG
POSSESSION.
HARDEN FROM
OF CONTACT UNDER THE BASKET.
THISUT.
ABLE TO FINISH, PLUS THE FOUL.
PLUS THE58% AND WAS  QUARTER.
ISOLATION, AND JALEN RO
HARDE
FINISH.
I MEAN, HE OF COURSE HAS TIGHT
>> Kevin: DOUBLE ON DURANT,
MILLS, SHOT IN.
HE FAKES OUT BAMBA, WHO
WATCH BROWN.
HARDEN.NICE JOB OF
GETS IT INSIDE, AND DURANT HAS
19.
>> Sarah: OH.
HOW PRETTY W
DRAYMOND GREEN EASES OVER,
UP AHEAD, DURANT ATTACKS THE RIM
AND FLUSHESWHAT A EURO FROM THE!
A THINGITH THE CONTESTSMART.
>> Doris: SMAR
POPOININTSTS 9 9 B BOAOARDRDS.S.
JAJAMEMESS M ME.E.
JAJAMEMES S HAHARDRDENEN,, T THE
STSTEPEP B BACACKK THE
HARDEN, THE REBOUND, IN THE
HARDEN